yeah so what's um
okay so the album is out i
you know you've been getting a lot of
love yeah man
is it is it hard like is it harder to go
through this like uh
you know we're in a in a world now where
there's just very like like two or three
people that could really change your
life and they're like carl cherry and
whoever the [ __ ] is carl cherry at apple
music
yeah you know and it's like it kind of
sucks
because there's very like
little room to just like like you've got
it
you got to be like a cool guy almost you
got to be in that cool guy club
to get into like a lot of these
playlists and it's
i i think it's i think it's wack but
um is it hard like for you to try to
thrive in this environment like as you
know
being indie now being solo now
and trying to still you know compete in
that world because it's a hard world to
compete in man 100
it is um i think
you're absolutely right about it being
like a game where you got to know
these people yeah and it's really wet
because what if carl doesn't like you
yeah or what if you met somebody at a
party the co-part about it'd be so much
deeper than carl it'd be like no i'm not
i'm not
right but no no no no no no no this
that's so crazy i'm piggybacking on what
you're saying
it don't even get to carl because
two steps under carl you might have
[ __ ] pissed them off the wrong way
that could have been a [ __ ] that
wasn't even in music it just gets
wild and so um the number one thing that
i
made sure i kept in my psyche and just
my spirit while doing everything i'm
doing creating my music
being solo paying for videos doing my
rollout doing everything i'm doing
was just pure intentions it's just
knowing what i'm like my message why i'm
doing it which is purely to like
like teach and inspire like
freedom leadership ownership in my
people like i got enough people that
literally [ __ ] with me that's just gonna
listen
that like if even if that's 100 people
that i knew if i put it in music form it
would have just inspired them and turned
them up
and that's how i was coming bro like i
ain't even wasn't even really trippy
because i've had it at the highest
heights
as far as like billboard premieres
first video to play on revolt like the
third video was biggie
it was a video that wasn't in english
shine yeah it's the third video
ever played worldwide on revolt i didn't
have the biggest premieres
shout out to revolt i don't know who
watches it anymore
shout out to puffy you know shout out to
nadia shout out to the whole team it was
so many [ __ ]
now revolt early on was so fire we know
the original team
yeah you know what i mean the dana is
the [ __ ] the elves the
real original team that's our people but
um
we so i've had the highest heights of
[ __ ] premieres and i've had it where
just me and i can't drop the [ __ ] on
[ __ ] soundcloud or something god know
and then had a song that's streaming
[ __ ] millions of
streams that we don't own the masters to
because we know the game and our manager
owns it
however we just dropped that on a low
scale and it boomed
we low key was just like everybody
yeah travis and we got relationship i
really have i
thought travis reposted your your your
album you replaced the album
which in 2020 is huge my man's got his
own mcdonald's
meal you know what i'm saying gary my
son went crazy about it my son was like
dad
travis you know what i mean that's my
brother you still talk to travis yeah
like
yeah like we ain't like we ain't like
the everyday thing but that's my brother
yeah
right if i call him you know enough
times he gonna answer you for me that's
that nigga's huge
baby so i don't even take it personally
i remember the first time i met him
him and casey veggies were on the road
together and he opened up for casey
in scottsdale exactly and then now you
know jesus that part
it's crazy i mean we was [ __ ] jeezy was
opening for us
and yeah i mean i mean a lot of people
was up there ty was opening up you know
what was the uh tour you were on
in when i saw you guys in florida it was
after coming was this
on school school i was thinking that's
right it was scuba q vince isaiah
shot that was a crazy tour that was
mind-blowing life-changing
but that was that's what it is my
intentions has been pure luckily i've
been just blessed i got an incredible
partnership
and through my partnership my music been
speaking like because that's what i've
been on like i ain't
i'm funding everything so funny [ __ ]
like everything i've been funded so it's
like
you got an investor you say you got a
business partner is that kind of the guy
putting up the
hell some bread or you're coming with
your own bread bro like that's my
business partner
in my endeavors outside of music outside
of music but when it comes to
your [ __ ] it's my music is solely me
like you know what i'm saying having to
go through it like damn let me
listen man take them let's do this
camera
let's make it this long then cause you
know cuz